how's it going everybody there is a lot
of stuff happening right now in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
just around the corner is Captain Marvel
Avengers for spider-man far from home
and the Doctor Strange sequel begins
filming early 2019 it's going to be
interesting to see how all of these
movies connect since they're coming out
so close to each other we have Captain
Marvel which is coming out before and
leading into Avengers 4 then Avengers 4
it will wrap up the storylines of the
last 10 years of the MCU and then
spider-man far from home we'll kick off
the next phase of the MCU real quick
reminder about the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway if you would like to enter all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so again there's a
lot to talk about with all of these new
movies coming out especially since they
connect to each other but something
interesting just happened samuel
l.jackson shared this photo to Instagram
this is from the set of spider-man far
from home
that's right spider-man far from home
will now have samuel l.jackson as Nick
Fury in it this photo shows samuel
l.jackson fake facial hair that he uses
to play the character Nick Fury this is
quite interesting because I thought his
facial hair was real apparently not
welcome
although the photo isn't spectacular it
does however confirm that samuel
l.jackson will be in spider-man far from
home as Nick Fury and this does actually
confirm a fact for Avengers 4 we have
two characters that were turned to dust
and Avengers infinity war appearing in a
movie that takes place after Avengers 4
so the Russo brothers can tell us that
the characters that died are permanently
dead all they want but clearly they come
back somehow hey you got some acorns on
you kid so we're left with two questions
one how did they come back there's many
theories and speculations on this
especially since time travel is involved
anything's really possible and two what
is samuel l.jackson role as Nick Fury
and spider-man far from home Avengers 4
is supposed to wrap up the stories from
the past 10 years of the MCU so why is
Nick Fury in London with spider-man
we'll have to wait till Avengers 4 comes
out to find out but let me know what you
all think let me know what you all think
Nick Fury's role will be in spider-man
far from home it also let me know how
you think everyone that got wiped out
from the snap comes back let me know in
the comments below and again the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway continues
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
to my channel like this video comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you all so much
for watching woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]